I don't know who jenna Marbles is I
don't know what she does
I don't know jenna Marbles I'm suddenly
a poem life is 15 million subscribers
maybe she does a beauty stuff workout
videos something with animals
if you were born really ugly like me
have no fear there's steps you can take
to be good-looking kind of she's not
ugly
she's right right she's like a beach
model I'm surprised at how hard she's
being on herself
she's mad witty and uh self-deprecating
which I like I do like that she's like
putting herself out there and mean like
I have a retainer it's like makes me
feel better than I also have a retainer
like funny because we've all like said
that kind of stuff where you've like
looked in the mirror and be like oh my
god like what's happening yeah Rick
commentary on the flaws in our society
are like spot-on and she does in a way
that doesn't seem like she has an agenda
and it makes you laugh yeah my eyelashes
are so real I don't wear fake lashes
there's a lot of boobs there is some
boob I can say that all the time
this is a video that probably guys
watching they're like amen this videos
like three minutes long and apparently
there's a ton girls lie about this is
news to me yeah we lie about a lot of
things men always ask like what's wrong
when they know what's wrong and you're
like nothing cuz you need to tell me
what's wrong I don't know this is also
just like boom boom boom like instant
instantly paying off I hear if you kiss
someone you trade faces with them wow
she looks like she's genuinely having
the best time ever she's relatable yeah
she's a relatable person like I would
hang out with this girl well I want to
face about my face on two different
things big Abraham Lincoln like saw this
video he would just be like what are you
doing America with your time
he's taking the Face Swap to the next
level right here an extreme level
I think she's carving out her own little
piece in the world to be funny and do
the thing that she wants to do because
looks like that's authentically her like
no one's telling her what to do and the
fact that she's making such relatable
content is like really really great I
think people take themselves so
seriously so I think people probably go
watch her so they can like laugh at
themselves and her and altogether you
know I won to put like a jar of marble
marbles in my mouth and I never could I
never did I just meet which one is it
you couldn't or you never did